beloved canadian author robert munsch
has revealed he's been diagnosed with
dementia
yeah known for books such as i love you
forever and the paperback princess
robert discussed his diagnosis for the
first time during an interview on cbc's
radios the next chapter explaining he
can no longer write among many other
things
well i have ongoing dementia
um
i can't drive i can't ride a bicycle i
can't can't write
so
it's been really whittling away on who i
thought i was
i kind of thought i would like to do
this the interview was the last hurrah
i i really appreciate your your being
with us and
getting the diagnosis what what went
through your mind when you when you
heard that that's what you were dealing
with
well i already knew i was dealing with
something
and there was a relief to get it in
black and white
but um
oh i don't like it
but
i mean that's in the cards that you get
so
now if i were god in charge of the world
i'll make it illegal
oh my goodness this is like uh
robert also admitted he's worried about
what his life will look like in a year
but explained his iconic stories will
always remain number one in his mind and
back in 2009 e.t canada sat down with
robert after his induction into the
canadian walk of fame where he looked
back on becoming a children's author
after originally studying to be a priest
the ongoing progress of the disease is a
pain
it's i i i worry about what i'll be in a
year
will i be a turnip in a bed in a year
what what does it mean for you as a
storyteller are your stories still there
still with you
um my story is strange enough are all
there
um
i i don't do shows anymore
i don't do
i don't even do school visits anymore
sometimes i tell stories to people just
people i've met
so
the stories will be the last thing to go
i think
i started telling stories in daycare to
make kids shut up for nap time it was
that simple um and i didn't think they
were special i thought anybody could do
it
and it didn't take any preparation it
just could you know the cook would yell
it burn i said oh the story time
um
and uh
but the kids asked for ones that they
liked
over and over again so the
the lousy ones disappeared and they made
me memorize the good ones okay and
the good ones are
well there's one called the paper bag
princess
i didn't even have titles for these it
was the dragon story tell us the dragon
story
i didn't know what i was doing
man i was that kid
tell me the story about um princess and
you know right away think about i love
you forever i'll like you for always as
long as i'm living my baby you'll be and
i read that my kids when they were
growing up and i'm like so sad but uh he
wrote some of the most iconic stories
um i don't think anyone has ever made
stories the way he did and he just knew
how to connect with kids with his
storytelling and when things like this
happen and he realized it was happening
to him and finally getting diagnoses is
important but
man he is a legend when it comes to
telling stories for kids and
just thinking back as a kid and to be
able to share that with my kids it's
definitely a feeling so ah yes
thanks for the story it is so sad this
is this is terribly heartbreaking i mean
for anyone but you know when you are a
creative and you write stories and that
is your outlet your mind is is your
outlet and to have to feel stuck in your
own mind and your own body is torture um
i have just so much empathy and
compassion for this this is
horrifying um i'm glad that he knows
what's going on
like the diagnosis is very important it
helps um you know forward motion and
kind of preparing for it but regardless
this is just
it's really sad it's really sad
ah
it brings back emotions man
yeah no he knows how to choose
i mean thank you robert for
being part of our childhood really
appreciate it yes oh i love that
sangeeta there are people in the
comments that are just you know such
fans of him as well so that's really
nice to see um so a lot of love to you
robert